andres gomez emilson hello again brother
hello again brother how is it going
i'm so excited that
we'll get another round together after
almost two years since the last round
yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's been it's been a
while
that's right
and we've done several episodes
with
qualia research institute we've done
several episodes on
consciousness
we had the computational properties of
consciousness we had the chemistry of
consciousness
now we'll be unpacking also energy and
consciousness yeah and
we'll get to hear about a good amount of
what's transpired over the last two
years for qri
and and also just
like mystically and quantum mechanically
that should like yeah that's pretty much
like the core of you know science and
spirituality merged
uh
and where the riddles are at
yeah
it's happening it's happening
yes
cool
so
why don't we
why don't we start things off with this
question and then we'll have you
um slot in
any time you need us to visit some of
the stuff that's transpired over the
last couple of years as examples and
information we can pull that up visually
so
let's start with
how does
energy
how does what underlies everything
create this
yeah yeah great
yeah we we're going right into it andres
there's no simple stuff uh when you have
me
interviewing
it's it's it's all good it's all good
how does energy come out of nothing and
how you know these like crazy energetic
exchanges uh that are happening every
day like where do they come from um i
think uh
i've thought very deeply about this
question i have a a a a video essay on
it uh basically if you go to my youtube
channel it's called
why does anything exist or you know why
is there something rather than nothing
and
i'll say the following like a i think
a lot of people dismiss this question
mostly because the style of explanations
that you may kind of like require
in most kinds of problems simply don't
apply here right like most types of
explanations are based on for example uh
causal structures uh
and uh of course like when you're
talking about like how does something
why does the castle structure exist to
begin with then you're kind of like left
in a way that you know you actually need
to exit that frame if you want to get
any kind of answer so ultimately i think
like the kind of explanation that we
will get will not be
of the sort of
how was the universe caused because
again that's kind of like assuming the
frame of causality
instead i think the kind of frame that
we should be investigating is one of
implication it's not that the universe
was caused by something is that the
universe is
implied or entailed or like logically
necessary as a function of something
else that is primary and actually
impossible for it to not be the case
and the thing that i think um
basically there's like three lines of
evidence that i think like kind of
converge in the same point which is
um and this is from david pierce it's
called um
uh zero ontology but basically there's
something very curious and i'll
kind of like briefly outline
these three things which is
what exactly is zero or what exactly is
nothingness that we have like such a
difficulty actually grasping or
imagining it whatever we imagined it as
obviously obviously it's not it um
so
my claim would be that actually we
currently have a pre-theoretical
understanding of nothingness that there
is such a thing as nothingness it is not
what we are trying to imagine when we
bring up that word is something much
more profound
and
uh and uh it shows up in three
completely different places
that i actually suspect are the same
thing from different angles so number
one is
physics
like it seems that the total energy of
the universe is actually zero if you add
up the potential energy and the negative
energy that comes from um yeah basically
like space expanding you add all of that
together that's zero if you add together
the total electric charge of the
universe that also is zero um the same
with like many other properties you know
the total curl or the total divergence
in the fields of physics all of that
comes down to zero um
and uh
in a way you know in quantum mechanics
yes like many of the things that you
will see is kind of like
how kind of like from the quantum void
you get like a particle and an
anti-particle and there's kind of like a
universal accounting system to make sure
that everything actually adds up and i
think like you know anything that exists
will have kind of like that underlying
accounting system
that from a strange angle maybe it makes
it equivalent to
nothingness or equivalent to the void in
a strange way maybe in reality it's kind
of like the void scene from a different
point of view that's number one the
second is mathematics that like
essentially every number implies every
other number right like you cannot have
the number 42
without the number 43 or without the
number two right like they all entail
each other they're it's not that the 40
is not that the number 42 causes
the number 43 is that the number 42
entails or implies the number 43.
and
the kind of like observation here is
that maybe
really the um the the the number that
really exists is um
uh oh no i think you're a bit frozen but
okay i'll continue which is um
uh the number zero
which is
okay hi
yeah i froze on the desktop and
i'm uh now on my laptop the same issue
came up yesterday i thought the desktop
had
come up with a solution to it
but apparently not so i will
power
cycle my desktop while i use my laptop
so please do continue perfect yeah yeah
okay so like the number 42 did not does
not cause the number 43 right it's not
like it's like it's not a causal
explanation
the number 42 implies the number 43
they're logically necessary one another
likewise we think that you know maybe
the number zero
is like truly a fundamentally necessary
like you can't get rid of the number
zero
and
it implies the rest of the numbers i
mean in there's a lot of like cool
mathematical constructions of how you
can get from the empty set you're going
to create like any number by nesting the
empty set in interesting ways
so that and that's math the final one
which i is the one that actually excites
me the most is
phenomenology that actually on these
like very
like advanced stages of meditation or
you know the extreme cases like 5m or
dmt
you can actually experience i think zero
ontology first hand where basically uh
there's this very common experience in
buddhism they call it the rainbow body
where like basically everything is
experienced as kind of a diffraction of
like the one light you know speaking
metaphorically or or or literally
depending on who you talk to
and
there's kind of this diffraction of all
of the possible colors and feelings and
sensations at once
and then
you look at it from a different angle
where like they all line up perfectly
and it all cancels out and you actually
get kind of this
void and kind of you you can go back and
forth
and like on a low dose of 5 million dmt
this is not that rare like it you know
it's maybe one in five a chance that you
may actually experience kind of this
phenomenon and i would say that that is
probably a phenomenological
demonstration of zero ontology that like
yes actually consciousness is
fundamentally kind of this you know void
with zero information
but it is kind of an unstable void and
you can
energize it and it will diffract and it
will create all of its possible colors
and that is not just a theoretical thing
it's something that you can actually
experience and i think it's like
something that can actually be studied
and
ultimately i also think that you know
consciousness uh
will
fit in the paradigm of physics and vice
versa physics will fit in the paradigm
of consciousness
and at least like very advanced stages
where you experience the rainbow
consciousness flip-flopping towards like
the void consciousness
that those will have like
very important physics equations that
describe them and like actually probably
yeah that that's kind of like the source
do you want to understand the big bang
probably understanding that type of uh
boundary in consciousness is very
important
i guess i'll add one last thing about
this whole zero ontology paradigm which
is that
what's really
uh kind of exciting here is that it
redefines
information so basically we tend to
think of information as like
you know state specifications as kind of
like oh like in a in a check in a in a
chess game it's like information is like
here's a pawn and here's a bishop and
here's a king
um but a different way of seeing
information is as the ruling out of
possibilities that like when you know
there's a pawn in here that means that
the pawn is not anywhere else like you
just ruled out a whole bunch of
possibilities
so in that sense like information is
taking off possibilities and what
xerontology would say is that what's
actually real
is zero information
but zero information
entails all possibilities that is like
when you say like i have a chessboard
but i can't tell you anything about it
that means any configuration is possible
right likewise i think it's kind of like
the the big bang and the universe is
like that it's like truly actually
there's no information
and as a consequence all the
possibilities are realized so that's
that's how energy creates the universe
wow
cool
wow that's the
analogy that you just wrapped with is so
cool
which is
that
if you're given
a
a boundless space and you're not given
any other information about what's
appearing onset boundless space
um
you'll never come to the end of
appearances onset boundless space
and
and i like how you broke it down into
you have a
a what is
zero
you have a math you have a phenomenology
and i like this style of breakdown i
think it's
insightful
uh to break it down into its components
and then try and synthesize them
um
yeah and physics and physics would be
the last one yeah physics
and phenomenology entailing spirituality
and mysticism union with god all this
type of stuff
and this also
really deeply plays into when we talk
about
the substrate
the substratum
that
it's becoming more and more of direct
experience not just concepts of the mind
the direct experience of the heart of
the gut viscerally
that
everything is the one light
and then that one light
appears
simultaneously
in
all of this apparent differentiation
yep and that's the beauty of it is that
when you see someone that is
locked into their apparent cage of
separation and conditioning
that that is the light
appearing
at a lower density
of consciousness than when the light
appears
as a higher density of consciousness
when there is no cage where it's just
the light recognizing itself and so
maybe that would be a good
question for you to ask is
if you did visualize it we could just
play with one way to visualize it which
would be the
light disperse dispersion through the
prism
into its
into it the visible light
rainbow
and so you have what appears to be this
source light oneness
of indescribable perfection that
everything always is
and then you also have what appears to
be this chakra system just like behind
andres yeah
and you see how apparently we see many
um
individuals pieces of life
that seem to be in this very yellow
chakra this very sort of solar plexus
shifting from solar plexus to heart and
then you see other mystics or yogis that
are just blasted through their crown
and
so now the question would be well how
does the how does the substratum how
does the substrate the underlying light
that everything is how does that emerge
as the appearance of something that is
either in this yellow or in this purple
and it all at the same time
yeah
yeah yeah well
there's definitely a lot to comment on
there i mean and like i i i i agree with
the overall kind of aesthetic like i'll
mention that
um there's maybe some twists interesting
twists because
uh i mean
a it is absolutely the case that like
consciousness has like different
densities and you know this is something
you can experience with meditation or
you know psychedelics um
the most like if somebody is like
complete non-believer that like there
are different different densities of
consciousness like you know 30
milligrams of dmt should be pretty
clarifying that like oh gosh actually
yes there's like these various like
energy bands
and it's not just one more band there's
like you know several several above like
the one that we uh we tend to imagine as
like the normal one
and of course all of them will if
they're locked in they will
believe themselves to be the one normal
way for consciousness to be which is
yeah obviously not like we are in a very
you know specific type of configuration
and uh we don't notice it because it's
like fish swimming in water essentially
um
but uh i i will make the
so roughly speaking
lower densities does give you more
flexibility and that's like nice more
fluidity
and as a general rule you will find that
like lower density states of
consciousness
are in a sense like
it's harder to get stuck in them in a
bad configuration but it's not by any
means uh impossible unfortunately
and likewise i would say like in the
lower density realms there's also
like very loving very blissful
configurations that are actually i would
say like aligned with a hole
um it's just that they may have like
somewhat more limited information and
like limited fluidity and flexibility
but uh it doesn't make them like bad in
in any way so um
i would bring up more kind of um
like there's a lot of kind of this this
trope i guess you know in a lot of
circles so like like all we have to do
is increase our frequency
and i think like maybe to a first
approximation actually that can be
really good and i can explain in detail
why that can be really good
but the deeper story is that the
frequency is only a piece of the puzzle
and actually the the thing that matters
the most is harmony
and harmony can actually arise in any
level of consciousness
just as dissonance and this harmony can
also rise in any level except
probably the absolute highest which is
actually just positive
for
for reasons that have to do with uh
symmetry and and the geometry of the of
the of the configuration of experience
that
yeah essentially super ultra high energy
consciousness tends to be just pure
positive
because it doesn't have like other
configurations but anywhere else there
are both you know there's both the dark
and the light side within every every
you know rio and like
you know somebody somebody who might be
skeptical of that also is kind of like
yeah you can take dmt and you can
encounter some pretty nasty entities
over there in the in the higher you know
and
uh realms of like lower density as well
um
and uh so it's not like a fail-safe
approach i think uh
um rather yeah thinking in terms of uh
harmony like understanding that in a
sense
is not about like you know the best
music is not just like music that plays
like the highest notes all the time it's
music that is properly harmonized
and
that is like much more sophisticated
because you require the math of harmony
and even for music that's uh pretty
tricky and when it comes to like
three-dimensional embodied objects like
us actually the math of the harmony of
those objects is a lot more tricky which
is i mean ultimately yeah but we are
studying at qri that where this is like
our
one of the main pieces of our thrust is
like can we figure out the music theory
of consciousness
okay
i like that so if we were to play with
this music theory of consciousness if we
were to play with
the
harmony
if we were to
be able to envision
this
both zero point energy
shunyata
nothing void
simultaneously as we envision infinite
creation infinite manifestation infinite
appearance
and we're able to envision that as both
an absolute
oneness
at the same time as
a sort of dispersion of differentiation
that then there's a music theory
of consciousness around
how
that codependent arising emerges as what
appears to be a more harmonic
versus a more dissonant
state of being of expression
yeah no absolutely and uh
there's a there's so much in here like
one one very important piece um is um
even the i mean you have this kind of
zero point point of like
um
we call them you know like a more
technical term is like
like very high valence states of
consciousness and in particular the ones
that we are talking about here would be
high valence high energy state of
consciousness which obviously connects
to the whole question of energy and uh
we will bridge it in a second um
but uh
basically we think that
like what gives rise to the dissonance
in our experience is actually uh
asymmetries in the shape that is our
consciousness
and
the analogy that we can think of it is
like if you have kind of a
a ball that has like a lot of hairs this
is called the hairy ball theorem
it doesn't matter how you comb it
it will always have like a hair sticking
out
and so there are some configurations of
consciousness that like you know you may
rearrange the deck chairs so to speak
you know
the thoughts and ideas and the feelings
but it doesn't matter how you rearrange
them there's still something that feels
off it doesn't fit properly and it's
like it's an impossible puzzle i mean
just as like combing as fear it's
impossible it mathematically it will
always have the kind of this like
sticking
sticking hair uh or vector
but if you try to comb a donut you can
actually do it that you can comb a donut
circularly
and it doesn't have anything sticking
out of it so i would think that yeah
basically a lot of these kind of deeper
transformations on consciousness through
a lot of meditation or take the 5 meo
dmt experience when people say like you
know it was perfect it was perfectly
aligned there were no
internal tensions or dissonances
it is like a perfectly calmed field
like it just the the awareness field
lines are just not intersecting with
each other
it makes this yeah beautiful kind of
toroidal energy system you know to speak
more more loosely and uh
and here's like what uh what i'll say
like people who experience this they
will often say like you know that was
ultimate reality that was perfection
i'll mention this
um
there are many other shapes that have
that property that may even fit more
energy so i think like a kind of like
maybe us is kind of developing souls if
you will um
uh
yeah basically
it's like we're kind of like a sphere
are we like upset that we can't calm
ourselves like fully and be completely
satisfied and then like maybe we do very
serious practices and all of a sudden we
can reshape ourselves into a taurus and
think like wow okay this is perfection
what we don't know is that there's this
other you know like way more advanced
entities that can shape themselves into
those four dimensional manifolds that
can also be comped except that they can
store like thousands of times more
energy and like explore thousands of
times more configurations so
my my intuition is that yeah i mean kind
of in the
the the levels of possible
peak love experiences or people police
experiences we're barely scratching the
surface like even the things that we say
are perfect
there's still a special kind of perfect
and there's like many other varieties of
perfection that uh are just yeah not not
explored currently
i'm curious in this
hairy ball theorem yeah could it be that
that little hair that's jutting out
it could that be one of those
patterns of conditioning
one of those trigger points
so it's like the perfect little
piece of hair that's sticking out
exactly
for a catalyst to come and hit it so
that it then has to like turn inward and
analyze that oh yeah conditioning to
awaken more
yeah that's a great point that's a great
point
yeah think of it as like a
at a trigger
trigger point is not about it not a bad
analogy here because
if somebody triggers you
right somebody says like x is not true
but part of your core belief system is
that x is true there's like somebody
coming to your sphere and trying to like
you know
come with that little hair
but then like that has like profound
implications right because the like the
spheres cannot be calmed anyway so like
the the
you know it's kind of you're rob they're
rubbing you the wrong way literally in
this analogy and like the uncombed hair
will start propagating and then like all
of the sphere will become kind of
haywire and uh you'll need to rearrange
yourself and yeah it's a very big task
uh
whereas yeah if you're a somebody who
are kind of like living in a taurus
consciousness instead um maybe you're
untriggerable people cannot trigger you
there's no place where you will have
like a strong reaction because
everything is perfectly smooth and
cumped
i love that and also that
if you're
really purifying yourself of all of your
separation and all of your conditioning
then you will earnestly get a reflection
from someone
and you will turn on that little hair
and you will
gently and lovingly
radically accept it
yeah and love it and then transcend it
and then
the hair ball
shift
energetically and then a new level of
hair will pop out right
the next catalyst that comes
in a month or whenever the next one
comes
when the next um even more deep pattern
of conditioning
propagates itself
into the field where if you if you look
at it from the very
source itself
into the field using the mind-body
spirit complex that's here
into the field
that when every single from the source
of perception itself
when
every single utterance into the field is
of that density expression
it's more pure service
it's more
in honor in
serving creation awakening rather than
extracting for
the unit of self that it's identified
with
how does that how does that style
resonate as well along with this
energetic emergence that
the
uh the emptying of self is what happens
at as the core
uh insight as one uh increases in
density of life
huge huge uh overlap so here's what i
have to say so
uh i mean i very much we very much think
at qri that uh consciousness is actually
a field um and like the way the brain
works is that it's a pinching making a
topological pinch on the field of
consciousness and
is using the holistic behavior of of the
field in order to do computation which
is yeah a crazy thing i mean from this
perspective evolution actually the
reason it cares about consciousness is
because it's a very efficient
computational system
energetically and
you know in terms of runtime complexity
but then like you know it's actually
recruiting you know a tiny piece of you
know universal consciousness to do you
know the the beating of the genetic uh
you know selfish gene or whatever it may
be uh
but uh but no i mean consciousness
itself has interests and one of the
things i talk about is uh
consciousness versus replicators that
like we currently are in a point in the
evolutionary history where
the actual desires and
um what consciousness wants
has a chance of manifesting in reality
um that like in a sense like through us
we can choose to actually try to benefit
consciousness rather than just our
selfish genes you know or just you know
patterns that are good at making copies
of themselves i mean that there's a lot
of them like from viruses to
you know
infectious memes or you know toxic ideas
to all the way to kind of like um yeah i
mean essentially
something like
uh super computer
um you know self-recursive a silver uh
recursively improving ai and things like
that which is yeah kind of like counter
to like actually the the well-being of
consciousness which is truly truly what
matters
and the way in which that happens is by
the organism being shaped in such a way
that it convinces consciousness
that who it truly is
is whatever patterns is kind of like
keeping the consciousness hostage which
is a very crazy thing right like when
people have a very strong ego
is actually something like a stockholm
syndrome right it's like
the the patterns themselves are very
punishing
and in order for that punishment you
just do whatever they ask you to do
which is yeah just such a sad situation
it's like consciousness is being held
hostage by our yeah the the selfish
genes we could say
and uh the way which i think that's
fundamentally implemented
it has to do
with basically this concept of
um viscosity and agglutination
that our default mode of experience is
one where we're constantly kind of like
carrying a center of mass that we
associate as like this is the self or
this is my individuality or you know my
my history and hear my traumas and my
pains and my pleasures
and uh and it's a very visceral thing i
i don't think
it's only theoretical like you can
actually notice like
okay like where do i identify like i'm
just behind my eyes or like i'm over
here
or like maybe i am stuck in the diatic
relationship with somebody or basically
there's all of these kind of like points
where you get agglutination and
condensation that happens um and they
function as an energy sink uh actually
and
whenever things like that happen in your
nervous system which is that that's like
the default mode i mean that's like how
we we evolved and for the most part
that's what we are um
they function as energy sinks and also
as blockages basically waves of energy
cannot travel smoothly
because they get reflected and interfere
with these points of agglutination and
kind of a a long cycle of like you know
meditation uh annealing um neural
annealing meditation or psychedelics
can slowly actually break down
that center kind of like center of mass
and the breakdown will have like some
pretty um
uh
reliable kind of like stages
along which and i mean obviously the the
stages of insight as described in
mastering the the cortices of the buddha
the lens of like hey yeah this is like
annealing processes breaking down the
sense of self i think yeah that's a very
good lens to to make sense of all of
these
and it also explains kind of a
that like in a lot of kind of these
intermediate stages between like hey
like a fully condensed ego and a
non-ego kind of field of consciousness
there's like a lot of strange
intermediate places where like there's
like ego fragments for example that are
like still being worked through and
all sorts of crazy things can happen in
in that process um
but you know apparently there's a light
at the end of the tunnel
but uh
but yeah i mean
the the the the thing to note here is
that um
i very much think that yeah it's
something like
like it is kind of like the hairy ball
theorem that like our sense of self or
ego has this like point of agglutination
of attention field lines
it is literally kind of like a place
where you have these uh vector fields
actually sticking out
and they function as kind of a trigger
points and they function also as uh
energy sinks and energy blockages so
anyway all of this yeah it's kind of
through the lens of a math and
anthropology
okay
this is great so
um could it be that
the
i'll share the word with you that i've
been playing with that um i think fits
into this perfectly i've been calling it
a neuro
not
k-n-o-t
a neuro knot a nero nut awesome yeah i
know i like it
yeah nearly not okay
so that yeah i'll uh i'll write it here
also for people yeah yeah no
not so it it looks like this
neuron
and
so
it's been fun playing with this because
it's
it's as though there was this character
called alan
a couple of years ago
that had a lot
more of a neuronaut of conditioning
and
egoic patterns of behavior a much more
contracted energy of expression trying
to extract
in relationships all this type of stuff
and now there's the appearance of this
atlas character now
and that this atlas character
feels like so much of that
neuro knot is totally liberated
that so much of the patterns of
conditioning so much of the patterns of
ego so much of that has dissolved so
much separation has dissolved so much
more recognition of the underlying
suchness is now present in the
moment-to-moment experience an awake
presence of love and compassion
and so
that's very interesting in relation to
the harry ball theorem it would
potentially be something like
that
as
we
dissolve more and more separation
that and dissolve more and more of that
conditioning that in a sense it's like
lighting the hairy ball on fire
and as though there there is yes this
this time where the hair the hair pieces
are all over the place and then they
slowly get less and less all over the
place and then it's only a little bit
left but we're burning it simultaneously
and then it's all burned up but now
here's the trick because
um
so this is the trick
is that there's what i would call a
quantum superposition that's happening
so
it's a quantum superposition because the
neuron knot
is both
filled with
conditioning
and separation but it's also filled with
the concepts
that
enable you to know that what an apple is
or when you know when andre says hey
atlas will you go grab the microphone
from the room you know you don't say i
don't
uh
you know what those symbols mean and so
this is what i say after that is an
empty polymath
so the
the ball the hair ball has been
completely burned
in this ascent
completely burned but it's in a
superposition where you can very easily
access at as needed the proper concepts
so how does in in place
[Laughter]
let me see a couple a couple of things
so um
the first one is yeah i mean there is
this saying in indian buddhism that like
uh
you know the the first stages is kind of
like where um in a sense like everything
you're able to kind of like start to
visualize like you know higher realms
and like a lot of like interesting stuff
and it's very very kind of like based on
form maybe very sublime you know you may
encounter like you know deities like
tara or you know whoever it may be
but it is kind of like a play of form
and then there's kind of like this stage
where basically you leave behind form
and it's all about basically formless
consciousness
um but then there's like an even more
advanced stage which is like the
combination of both like simultaneously
and i guess like
hearing from um uh
frank yang as well like he was
describing that like after his big
awakening
the way he describes the phenomenology
is which
is stuck with me very deeply because
this sounds really awesome he says like
he he feels like now he's permanently in
a superposition of
ninth agenda which is like beyond being
a non-being
together with i think like fourth jana
uh
which or like fifth gen infinite space
um
together with like normal everyday life
consciousness and they're all
simultaneously present and
that that actually sounds like
an amazing you know
hedonic value an amazing way of being
that like
uh if you can have direct access to
these like different modalities of
consciousness simultaneously and they're
in harmony like that that seems yeah
like a
i mean again from the music theory
perspective the music theory of
consciousness perspective
those are like these very precious gems
in the states of consciousness that are
like you know you need a lot of mining
and a lot of refinement to find them but
like uh if you can you know it's a an
amazing lifelong improvement um
uh i guess like a another the other
thing that comes to mind is um um
yeah i mean with a 5mao dmt
i mean the explanation that we have at
uh at qri is that uh and this comes from
mike johnson basically uh
there's an overlap between five million
dmt and mdma
in that
they both seem to essentially give rise
to
uh a feeling of a unified field in your
in your body
and and mind where like waves propagate
waves of energy propagate without
resistance
and uh and like how could that possibly
be the case one one possible
neurophysiological explanation is that
we have a lot of different types of
neurons and so like if you look at the
spiking um you know the spiking curves
of like electric potential for neurons
over time
uh depending on the neuron that will
look very different like a serotonergic
neuron the spike looks very different
than a dopamine neuron than an
mda neuron
but we suspect that 5mu dmt makes
neurons spike in the same way
uh even if they're different types of
neurons of course this is an empirically
testable prediction we don't know it's a
hypo hypothesis but it would make sense
because
that would mean that neurons are very
different types like for example your
language centers and your visual centers
and so on
all of a sudden can
exchange energy seamlessly with each
other because they spike in exactly the
same way they have the same energetic
dynamics
and
phenomenologically i mean on a low dose
of 5mu dmt what you will experience is
you have your conditioned patterns kind
of like all over your nervous system and
then you have this undercurrent of a
universal field of energy where with
where energy can move through without
resistance
but they're both kind of simultaneously
and actually a lot of it will feel like
the field of energy behind is like
teaching
your patterns of conditioning
hey this is why this is so decent or
like this is the problem that you have
like stuck inside you like look it would
be so much easier if you could just
manage energy in this unified field
because you don't get stuck you don't
get these patterns of dissonance
in higher doses
of course there's like this interplay
where
as the energy in the unified field
increases
the patterns of conditioning become very
scared and actually may experience a lot
of dissonance and then there's the
critical point of like whether you let
go in which case you
become the unified energy field
or whether you resist and you end up
being this dissonance between the
unified field and
your you know pastiche uh feels as we
usually would be um
but uh i i think
uh i mean if if you
let go
but are still okay with kind of like
patterns of conditioning i think you can
have like exact you know you can have
your cake and eat it too that's my my
suspicion that like it's not gonna be a
that hey you have to abandon everything
yeah
you can have your aid and eat it good
would be that how would uh close close
that reflection
i'm really glad that you shared what
what frank has been sharing with qri as
well
and yeah
he's mentioned you guys several times
when we've been featuring them on the
show and whatnot nice
yeah and
because it does
it does really feel like
more and more
a
an absolute
unboundedness an infinite spaciousness a
pure potentiality that's indescribable
also a
total
awake presence but also an ineffable
transcendence
and then it also feels like a total
ordinary person
yeah so
he's
you're like you are infinite space while
you're having a conversation with
someone at the grocery store
yeah
and
that is uh
you're
totally present with them
um
and you recognize that it's just
infinity talking to itself
and
you
are also totally transcended out of the
dream that is the universe
and
it
these these feelings
that
begin intellectual
um
[Music]
they become more experiential
and then you really begin feeling them
in your heart and in your gut and they
become visceral
and
moment-to-moment experience becomes that
and any time you sort of stray away from
being bound the space and you get into a
couple discursive thoughts
oh my gosh
it hurts
it hurts it hurts so
much
to contract the energy it hurts yeah
that's what it is it's a it's a
contraction or as you say it's a
dissonance
this the dissonance hurts
in in comparison to the harmonic
yeah
yeah
relative relative to nirvana
everything hurts
even an ice cream even even tea
yeah that's been a big theme that we've
been chatting with frank about on the
show and i'm glad you brought those up
and
it feels like another important one for
us to
to play with is
so
are we thinking
that
that if we were to maybe
create a visualization
that there's
and we'll use concepts to try and
explain this as best as we can but that
we have a
zero point energy
and then we have some sort of
quantum field
theory with
electromagnetism light
infused with love
that oneness
that is then
appearing
as
form
as separate form
that is then also differentiated based
on its density of light
so there's again it was
zero point energy quantum field theory
uh
electromagnetism love light
and the appearance of differentiation in
densities of consciousness as form how
does yeah how does that resonate with
what you've been studying
yeah i mean i'll i'll comment a couple
things uh
maybe the first one yeah is uh
i mean if in quantum mechanics like zero
ontology i think like fits really well
um
the
content that i would recommend anybody
to look at is uh
uh in youtube you actually can find like
a series of four lectures by richard
feynman on quantum electrodynamics and
they're very very accessible i think
like a non like if you never studied
physics
you have a high school math but like a
desire to really understand it like
he explains it super well for like a
general audience and
uh
basically yeah i mean what what
is the case in physics and it's crazy
is that
uh the problem like the probability of
observing certain event
given some other event is basically you
think of
the initial conditions and the point of
observation as boundary conditions
and literally what happens in between
those two
is that every possibility gets realized
it's just that most of them end up
canceling each other out they cancel
each other's amplitudes and you just get
often times it's just going to be the
shortest path in some corner cases you
actually get like light travels through
the longest path as well which is an
interesting result from from the same
theory
um yeah most people think that light
only travels through the shortest path
but actually sometimes it does through
the longest path and
and it's for the exact same mathematical
reasons um that like every other path
cancels out except what's called the
extremists in physics um
and uh all that you ever observe i mean
i mean this is i'm just gonna joke here
but like all that you ever observe is
actually the extremists of physics
meaning that in some deep sense
um extremism is true
uh anyway that's kind of like a geeky
physics joke but yeah extremism is true
because all that ever happens is the
extremism physics which is basically
shortest paths or longest paths
and and that is derived through
literally
just adding up all of the possibilities
at once and then just doing what's
called a path integral that essentially
cancels out almost all of them except
the shortest path but the other ones
still happened it's just that you you
didn't observe them you they're not
affecting you because they're kind of
canceling their own influences so
the idea here is that well that happens
when you have two boundary conditions
but in the big multiverse in the
entirety of everything there is no
boundary therefore
actually what ends up happening is all
possibilities actually become realized
so
um it's kind of like if you take the
fame and diagrams but without a boundary
condition i think that would be my
explanation of actually what's going on
for why there's something rather than
nothing um
and the those finding diagrams is the
only way in which you can actually
maintain zero information so everything
yes kind of this universal accounting
system uh again uh everything being pure
consciousness at the bottom of it um
and uh and the second thing i want to
share is uh actually if you google in
quality computing it's called healing
trauma with neural annealing and uh and
if you share that the screen of that
i'll
i'll show you um
uh a picture that i think is very
relevant for what we're talking about
healing trauma with neural annealing
right yes
there's actually quite a few
really good slides in in there too to
maybe like briefly touch upon
but uh yeah actually let's just go
through a few of them and uh
and and i'll get to the diagram that i
want to show you as well in a second
okay so this is
this is what i have up
here
is this correct
yes
yeah so if you go down a little bit so
the first slide actually
after the the video
uh that one
psychedelic epistemology
yeah so this is i mean some people may
add you know people ask like
why should i listen to you about like
states of consciousness and psychedelics
and so on um
i mean here's the reason like you know
at qri you know in quality computing
we've been like putting a lot of effort
into actually systematizing this like
actually like mapping out the state
spaces saying
uh
new you know meaningful and non-trivial
things about this states of
consciousness rather than just you know
i saw pretty colors or something like
that or just saying something like oh
and it was exactly what alan watts said
which is also cool but it's not
necessarily advancing the field as much
but the
one very deep reason is that a we
basically are very systematic uh about
like cataloging the state space
uh b we actually tried to find the core
dynamics that explain everything else uh
so like
it's kind of like we
if a biologist is just interested in you
know describing beetles that's not as
like as general as like trying to
describe how evolution
works and and the same way
somebody may be honing in on a specific
meditation practice what we're doing
instead is like finding what are the
principles that give rise to different
kinds of states of consciousness
but then the the third one is really
kind of like a ashanga of serious
psychonauts you could say that like
since 2015
you know that i've been writing up you
know articles like how to secretly
communicate with people in lsd or
algorithmic reduction of psychedelic
states i've been receiving a lot of
correspondence from like
a lot of different kinds of people some
of them are like very crazy like i
definitely get like correspondence of
like oh i took dmt and the reptilians
are real and they're controlling the
world like i definitely get like that
type of uh
that type of email but also i get emails
from like hey like i'm a phd
uh physicist from mit and i do dmt on
the weekends and like here's like my
thoughts and like i think your article
is correct for these reasons and is
wrong for these reasons so basically
and i connect those people to each other
so basically by now there's kind of like
a pretty solid like community
of actually super smart very systematic
people who have like very deep
experience in these things uh just to
give you like one
other um example here
is like we host these things called uh i
mean they're private events for obvious
reasons but
this thing called phenomenology club
where like basically we invite people
with like very deep experience in a
particular area and then we basically
interview them collectively and we try
to figure out if the models that we're
proposing align with their experiences
or or if if they don't and
uh so a lot of the content in you know
this article healing trauma with neural
annealing is really content that has
been
tested with people who have like very
deep experience and when i say deep
experience i actually mean it like
in the in the recent phenomenology club
where we were interviewing people who've
done a lot of 5mao dmt
um we had like three people in that club
who all of them had done five emo dmt
every day for six months like
like leo gura did it for like you know
25 days and made a video about it but
like here we are talking with people
who've done it every day for six months
and they're not crazy like they actually
like make sense and they can articulate
their experience and anyway so that's
what we call a
think tank model that like originally in
in most of science right now like what
is going on is that they do this kind of
like
third person perspective study they give
civil sabbing to like 100 participants
they fill out a questionnaire and that's
it like they don't even talk to each
other there's no in the scientists
usually are not actually interested in
like what they experience they're just
interested in like oh will the
questionnaire reveal a statistically
significant difference relative to
control or something like that
and then you have the other approach
which is the uh kind of individual
explorer kind of like john lily or sasha
shulkin going very deep
but then the the downside there is that
there's no critical feedback where like
they just kind of like go into their own
world
um
and write awesome books super
interesting but then
the output of that tends to look more
kind of a
the earth coincidence control office and
other other things like that as opposed
to like hey like what are the
mathematics of like consciousness so i
would say that yeah at qri we
legitimately are like a new model for
like how to study consciousness and like
it's really only possible because of
kind of a
a critical mess of people who are
you could say like are
a lie have like an alive thread on these
spaces um so anyway that's a chart i
wanted to show you i'm wondering if you
have any reactions to it
yeah immediately
is
the
reaction of
this is what happens
when
all of the
separate spiritual islands
and scientific islands
when they all come together into the
think tank model there is way more
mountains that can be moved in
maximizing collective prosperity
yeah
way more
insights
way more
uh distortion patterns being revealed
um
and
it's
it's exciting because
um
when the
uh the individual express shifted more
into the think tank model
that
um
that's what assimilation
you know really
is and uh
it's uh it's quite nice
[Music]
it's like when
i don't know it's very beautiful like
uh when you meet other like
i guess like deep practitioners in
and it doesn't have to be psychedelics
like i mean we also do this for like for
example like perfume
uh like we've interviewed people who are
like
expert perfumers and or like a perfume
reviewer and like but it's like very
similar as in like
these people who have been going very
deep into
like the subtle
gradients of a certain type of
consciousness that nobody else like
knows that there's like all of these
varieties and then it's kind of like you
have like this box of like your your
collector items stuff like oh this is
all that i've collected over the years
but nobody can appreciate it nobody
knows what i'm talking about and then
you find another collector it's like oh
my gosh i also have this one i don't
have that one that's cool exactly that's
so perfect and
one of the relatable ways to explain
this would be
remember i was sharing earlier how
if you keep your attention
on the very source of perception itself
if you keep your attention on suchness
itself
and then you're very vigilantly
watching every
spontaneous appearance emergence
happening
that
if you're really vigilant and really
subtle
you can become aware at what density of
consciousness words are being spoken at
in the field and out of your own
mouth
and so
then
when you pass time with
mystics
that have
underwent a more intimate union of
deconditioning themselves
and
from all separation from all ego
empty of self pure dao
that
their ability to
spotlight the patterns of conditioning
even at the highest levels as they leave
out of people's mouths
is unprecedented
and so that's one of the
top reasons to also enter into these
think tank models
is because of that exact profound
revelation
and to fearlessly go into the fire
yeah fearlessly yeah of course you will
be
those distortions will be pointed and
you'll have one part of you that's your
conditioning which is that
that selfish gene that
that desire for
for self proliferation
and then you'll have the
opposite of that
the truest capital s
self
that wants you to empty the [ __ ] out of
all of that [ __ ]
and
fearlessly walk into that fire my
friends
that's uh that's the entire game is
played right there so
yeah i mean not not to
these
all on all replicators because i mean in
the end
we will actually require a seamless
blend between pure consciousness and
replication so that we can carry the
torch forward we could say
yeah it's not that when you're
completely empty you never have sex
yeah
yeah
there aren't these mutually exclusive
you know
when you know the last in the
in the zen 10 bulls the very last one is
he's back in the market drinking wine
that's yeah
so you're you're still an ordinary bra
while you're an infinite bra
you still have that like you're saying
that um but it's it's not coming from a
place of separation like i need to
extract sex out of this scenario for
me to feel whole
stuff like that yeah yeah
yeah i mean
yeah
i'm very optimistic like
i mean this is obviously like a
not everybody will think the same here
obviously um
i suspect you actually will probably
find this idea pretty compelling but
it's very controversial i'd imagine i
don't know but like i suspect that
actually um
i mean essentially like
this like having like very reliable very
positive
techniques to like experience oneness
directly um
is not only good for uh for our health
and for our well-being and also for you
know like acting kindly to others and so
on i think it actually
will probably play an even bigger and
crazy role
which is it will change the game
theoretical landscape
um
so right now how society works is like i
mean essentially
the systems and institutions want to
work under the premise that you know
people are just
beating for their own interests and
maybe you know the interest of their
family their their kin and so on and of
course there's interpersonal variability
there's people who for example
experience like much more desire to help
people who are far away people who
experience much more desire to help
people who are close by and i think like
that diversity is all well and good
but uh ultimately
um a lot of kind of like the the systems
of of us you know the status algorithms
and so on that exist in the world do
kind of like assume
that like basically people perceive
themselves as separate
and
i i actually suspect that if there's a
reliable way of inducing like what we
call open individualism experiences
feelings of oneness um
in a way that is actually measurable and
is verifiable
it would actually change the landscape a
lot because you can make communities of
people who okay like maybe they don't
feel like oneness all the time but they
have access to it
and so even like in like conflict and
negotiation and like planning and
strategy
they can
in a sense
um
uh fast forward a lot of the kind of
like
um game theoretical impasses that tend
to happen simply because you can jump
straight to the fact of like well but
actually we're all one and like you know
we're just hurting ourselves by
keeping arguing within these premises
with this kind of like underlying
background assumptions of separateness
and the same happens with like i mean
like this is the the other side of the
coin which is
i think like oneness will actually truly
revolutionize
decision theory because if you look at
like a textbook on decision theory or
something like that they and game theory
they look at for example
like well you're assuming that each
agent is trying to maximize the area
under the curve of the utility of its
own life over time you know or something
like that or maybe it has a decay
function that's also typical in in those
fields they might say like uh like
people are trying to maximize their more
immediate well-being still taking into
account the further well being not as
much and
but that's kind of like assumed into the
theory they're like hey like people are
just like rationally selfish and that's
it
but actually
if you have people who truly believe in
kind of a oneness perspective i think
you can
shift towards what david peters calls a
god's eye view decision theory which is
like
how do you maximize the well-being and
happiness and love and understanding
from the point of view of kind of the
god's eye view and
i think that's just like a completely
different paradigm where
it's uh you don't have the in-built
background assumption of individuality
and
it's not a i mean there is kind of this
very loving like beautiful like
hippie-ish kind of quality to this idea
but actually i think like in math and
like in in economics it will actually
revolutionize how we think about power
dynamics how we think of institutions
we're not there yet and like there's
going to be a lot of things that need to
happen before like that actually has any
traction but i
i predict
it will actually shape a lot um
and uh like in you know a hundred years
from now
um this is going to be very this a very
crazy contingent uh of like it's not
just going to be like you know political
factions beating for their own interests
it's gonna be like sure political
factions like that but also
somewhat decentralized groups of people
who are actually just beating for the
sake of consciousness and they're like
developing protocols and developing um
methods to prove that actually they are
on the side of consciousness that is not
just a trick or a paragraph of a power
move because that is currently the
obvious suspicion right if somebody says
like hey i'm doing work for all of
consciousness people say like well you
know i'm sure you're just virtual
signaling i'm sure that's just uh you're
trying to impress us or you know
whatever it may be you're trying to get
money from us but if you can prove it's
like no actually
mathematically the incentive structure i
just created actually works out for a
heterogeneous mix of people who are just
caring about their own well-being and
people who are caring about
consciousness and it produces so much
more value than the previous paradigm
yeah i mean societies that adopt that
will actually just out compete every
other society um so
yeah i mean essentially the
the
uh i don't know how to describe it but
like yeah it's something kind of the
the real of pure consciousness i think
is not just a hippie
you know dream
it actually will probably like manifest
in terms of changes in game theory and
decision making and economics
yeah this is a perfect way to
slot in
the
the archetype
that is
decentralization or universalization
because
and this goes directly into oneness
suchness unity
this is that
this is
that
fungal network this is mycelium this is
a biogenesis this is one cell becoming
10 million species
you know this is that
yes
and so when you biomimic the planetary
social contracts with decentralization
and cryptocurrencies and fractional
ownership
and all of these great
inclusive stakeholding protocols
it's
game over because
because there's nothing other than that
because it it both
it both
empowers
the
it's just the collective's absolute
highest potential is when that style of
protocols in our social contract are
present
in maximizing abundance and prosperity
so it's a biological archetype it's a
universal
archetype it's what we are
the one that's being embedded into our
social contracts is exactly what is also
needed in order for the individuals to
actually be able to have their basic
needs be met for them to be able to not
only artistically express themselves but
also for them to be able to turn inward
and understand the nature of
consciousness the nature of reality and
so
all of this feedbacks on itself elevated
consciousness gets placed into the
planetary architectures elevated
planetary architectures feed right back
into elevating consciousness
um
i'll i definitely have something to
mention in here which is uh i mean i i
generally agree with that kind of a
uh general direction i'll point out
there's like some interesting
subtleties here which is
um
like for example like uh one may get
under the impression that like hey like
it would be better if everything was
fractally organized or something like
that because
if something
uh works at a certain scale and you can
create something self-similar at a
higher higher scale they will fit
perfectly together or something like
that there's kind of like a lot of
heuristics like that they sometimes work
not always and there's a good reason why
they don't always work which is that
actually
uh the scale of a particular system may
influence whether the system is
appropriate uh or not
so there's this uh whole concept um
uh yeah i mean i guess like one one
super concrete example is like people
may think
um
like well the the body the whole point
of like the body the like the
organization of the body is to maximize
flow and like it's true that like a lot
of like our veins and cardiovascular
system and
uh the organization of the of the
nervous system and so on it is kind of
like geared towards maximizing
interconnectivity like within the limits
of like its own geometry and the fact
that we live in 3d euclidean space
but it's not always maximizing flow or
maximizing interconnectivity
why because if it was doing that
at every scale
uh it would also be very vulnerable to
for example being
uh like infected with like a bacteria or
viruses so actually it's a very subtle
interplay where what you want is maximum
flow at certain scales
where resources can be distributed as
you know fast and homogeneously as
possible
but also you want the restricted flow at
other scales so that things like viruses
and bacteria don't propagate very well
and i mean i i definitely think that you
know right now we are experiencing a
cambrian explosion of like ideologies a
camber and explosion of self-organizing
systems of you know patterns of
distribution uh kinds of
decentralization and so on uh and i
think like
how they will play out actually in the
complex dynamic system that is the
entire world is a very non-trivial thing
i i generally do think that like you
know current systems are like overly
restrictive and we're in a gridlock
unfortunately for very deep reasons that
have to do with how uh power is
basically yeah ends up being in a
gridlock situation um
but uh i would be skeptical that you
know just putting everything on the
blockchain in a decentralized way would
actually
really fix that uh it might actually
just create a different kind of uh of
system
um that has like similar problems
so instead actually the the thing i tend
to
uh think as the most promising is
in a sense not putting the cart before
the horse it's like not committing to
any particular mode of self-organization
instead i think i'm very much in favor
of kind of this um
the seasteading aesthetic you know this
idea of like hey let's actually create
completely new societies that are not
under the you know the rule of any
current empire or any current country
um such that we can actually from the
bottom up try completely new you know
systems of organization with the new
technologies right this is not like
it's not about like let's draw feudalism
versus
monarchy or whatever it may be we're way
past that right like it would actually
be oh let's try this combination of you
know quadratic voting together with
blockchain in this particular way
together with um you know
new kinds of social relationships and
new drugs
and new
and see what happens right before we
roll it out into the rest of society we
should first try it out in a contained
society if it works really well then we
try it in something that is like twice
the size and we keep kind of like
doubling until it breaks and when it
breaks we learn the lessons of like okay
why doesn't this like scale higher but i
think yeah kind of like these like very
cautious
but also very imaginative and very open
approach um i guess like the the last
thing i'll add here is that i i do have
like
i do think like the locus of control of
the individual
should always be there for two things
one is
no society should be mandatory like to
be in one of these like exploratory
societies it should be an opt-in
like it's not like
currently like if there's a revolution
in your country
you know they're not going to allow you
to leave right like you just have to be
in that country and it sucks uh you may
not like the new regime or or the
previous one but like you don't have a
choice
in the sort of like systeming aesthetic
you always have a choice it's up to you
whether you want to go to a given
society
and the second one is um you can always
choose to pack your la pack your bags
and leave i think like that's the other
inalienable right for the individual
from my perspective like people should
always be free to leave
whatever society they're they're in and
i think like with that yeah like the
societies are actually better for the
individuals um and are good at
self-sustaining
um will basically yeah be the ones that
can like survive better as communities
and uh and i do suspect you know the the
full thing the thing that will actually
evolve
will probably be something that merges
kind of like in a very seamless blend
complete decentralized systems together
with some kinds of hierarchies and
overlapping hierarchies together with
some like anarchic style organizations
it's gonna be something that defies
current description like it's not gonna
be something you can say oh that's
capitalism or it's like no it's a new
completely new thing like those
previous
categories were kind of
when we were children as humans just
trying to make sense of social organisms
but actually there's
camera and explosion right like i guess
like what i'm trying to communicate is
like when people say like hey are you a
socialist or a capitalist or something i
hear it as like do you like dogs or cats
not realizing like oh my gosh there's
like dolphins too and there's elephants
and chimpanzees
there's just so many other possibilities
yeah
it will always be a synthesis will
always be simultaneity that is what the
oneness the suchness equanimity is it is
the synthesis it's the simultaneity so
always
right now what's calling more than
anything is the decentralization and the
universalization and the social contract
to be more around fractional ownership
and inclusive stakeholding but there
will definitely also be a bunch of
dolphins and anteaters and porcupines
and things that are unimaginable and
it's and it's awesome
uh okay i feel like a good place for me
to ask um
this question which relates to what
we're talking about earlier and it tries
to boil it down into even simpler terms
which is that
do you feel like light
is the fundamental mediator between
emptiness and form
[Music]
i think for
i mean like
yeah for a big portion of it
but actually i don't think for
everything um
yeah what else is there
yeah right uh i actually i forget the
name but like they're called like
carrier particles in physics like
um
i mean basically
you have light
but that's like
quantum electrodynamics so that's going
to be like how electrons and protons and
basically
like anything having to do with
electromagnetism how that
and that yes for sure is going to be
like
when you look at like uh the finding
diagrams of like two electrons moving uh
over time
the thing that makes them either go
closer together or separate is whether
they exchange electrons or not like that
sorry whether they like
exchange photons which is yeah light
so light light as particles will be the
carrier of like energy and interaction
between those particles but
uh is not all because there's also like
in the strong force i mean i forget the
the term i don't think it's muons but
like basically there's like
strong force carriers and like
they're different
they're completely different particles
um
so i mean maybe the most common one i'll
say something like that like generally
it's light but there's there's other
more crazy ones as well
so
what else is going on
between emptiness and form besides light
so quantum electrodynamics
everything that's happening is light
electromagnetic flux
what are what is the other one what are
the other
let me let me find it real quick
oh you're talking about the categories
of bosons and fermions and gluons is
inside of those categories yeah yeah but
i mean it's i mean i i do i do take it
seriously i mean like um
we are at qri we are what we call strong
monists
like basically we take the idea that
like you know spirit and consciousness
and physics they're all sides of the
same coin
and they're like absolutely everything
that you find in physics from like you
know super fluid helium to like plasma
waves to
all of these other crazy things
they all have a corresponding flavor of
consciousness
and in a sense i i mean i i think like
when you experience something like fabio
dmt um really full release experience
one interpretation is that what you're
experiencing there is the fully calmed
electromagnetic field that has like no
dissonance and like that is
yeah it feels yeah it's this univ it
feels like a universal unified field um
but it may actually just be the
electromagnetic field but there's other
fields as well and like in our normal
everyday life
basically they are they're all
interacting with one another and there's
so many different flavors of
consciousness as a result and like
for the electromagnetic component of
consciousness light would be the
interplay between form and emptiness
but for
other aspects other flavors of
consciousness it would be the glue one
or it might be something else like like
what
like uh the like what
and what would the glue on
um
because i'm
i'm looking at uh
these
two fundamental categories of
subatomic particles
yeah
bosons and fermions
what besides light
is happening
as the fundamental mediator between
us i think it would be all the bosons in
the extreme left so photons gluons
w
boson
higgs
i guess gigs would be for for mass
i mean this is definitely i mean i
haven't studied this academically so
i'm not i'm not a reliable source here
but uh
but but yeah i mean it would be
something like the carrier particles
would be the thing that is
in this very speculative explanation
space would be that yeah so so the the
core
question is something like
what besides light
quantum electrodynamics is happening
yeah i mean it could be like
um i mean there's one speculation which
is that
like actually
a lot of the qualia that we experience
has to do with the other fields of
physics rather than electromagnetic
electromagnetism and that
electromagnetism is more what gives rise
to binding what allows the different
quality varieties to come together into
unified experience in which case you
know
actually when you experience a
particular
uh smell as an example
like smell qualia could be what it is
like for gluons to interact with one
another or for delocalized glue ones to
coexist
um
again extreme extremely speculative so
i'm not putting a lot of stock in here
i'm just
giving you a
a crazy answer to a crazy question but
uh
um
i i do think though that yeah like a
binding like how
um
the pieces of information in your
experience are put together i think that
is actually patterns in the
electromagnetic field like obviously
this is
very controversial in neuroscience but i
have a lot of good reasons to believe
this and uh one researcher i would point
at for people
uh sir
yeah it's a susan pocket susan pocket
wrote a book about
uh electromagnetic field theories of
consciousness and i i thought it was
very compelling i mean i'm happy to
describe some of the arguments but but
basically what i arrive at is that
that
that research shows that it's very
likely that actually binding is
implemented with electromagnetism but
then there's the
additional question of
but what are the individual qualia
varieties like the feeling of smell or
tactile sensations and that might be a
different fields it's just that they're
bound i mean it's kind of like the
electromagnetic is kind of like
magnetism kind of the the magnets that
i'm putting them together into this
unified experience but then you need to
explain the building blocks and the
building blocks might be from the other
fields
so you hypothesize there is
other building blocks
yeah
so qualia is not only
patterns of
electromagnetism i don't think so
but it is the main one i mean is the
main way to affect consciousness
uh add the human form
but uh so what what underlies
even
all
light and whatever else
is still energy yes
so it's
still
energy
modulating
yeah
and changing
form so
because you can transform the energy of
a photon into a gluon or into a electron
like they're
interchangeable if you do the right set
of transformations
and uh
like the
lens here that i think is actually quite
literally something like
a weird rubik's cube
where like
electrons would be kind of like twisting
it in certain way
and then glue ones will be twisting in a
different way
but i mean in the end it's still
twisting you're still twisting this
object
and that would be energy
but then the type of twisting it
actually
like matters a lot for like what happens
well like there's some puzzles that you
cannot solve unless you have all the
moves available and likewise if you only
have like light you there's a lot of
transformations you you just can't do
you need to transform that light into
other forms of energy so that you can
then work that energy over there
cool you just use the word work so it's
energy doing work yeah
yeah work is literally energy
times distance right
yeah the transference of
energy and
also the potential
the
ability to do work
so
so also
vibration
the very
the very nature of that singularity
endlessly
expressing itself as pure potential
infinitely
boundlessly
forever
energy being
that
vibration
you'll never come to the end of all the
different ways that you can put notes
into a song
never come to the end of all the
different ways you can
put together images into a movie you
never come to the end of different ways
to paint a blank canvas
there is a i mean
romantically i agree
in a very abstract you know argument i
would say
there probably is a limit to how big an
experience can be and that limit is
probably
uh having to do with some
the nature of of uh physics so
uh and it's a completely open question
is that not boundless enough to
entertain you oh it totally is it's more
than enough more than enough for sure
so how about it dependent on that
experience of a metaverse bro yeah well
because i think there's a finite set of
possible experiences like the i know it
sounds crazy
but essentially i mean the argument is
not that hard it's
basically
if the amount of consciousness that you
experience is actually has to do with
bound energy
then the question is like what is the
largest possible
amount of bound energy that that can be
sustained anywhere in the multiverse if
you want
and i think the answer is not going to
be infinite um
because
you know if something actually is
infinite
parts within it you light will take an
infinite amount of time to to reach and
so like in some sense it's actually not
a unified thing
but it's entangled so it's not actually
traveling
i
even even with entanglement um
it's it gets tricky but basically even
with
quantumly entangled systems um
or quantum coherence systems the speed
of light still matters a lot um like you
can see this in super fluid helium like
if you cool down
helium all the way to like less than
like one degree kelvin uh it becomes
like this quantum liquid that is like
all one like literally it is not made of
particles anymore it's literally just
one wave and it's super crazy that that
happens but you know
you can do it in a lab
and even though it's like all not even
entangled it's like literally coherent
quantum coherent
um
with the waves of energy still take time
to propagate
so
uh just the fact that you have something
coherent to entangle it's not guarantee
of in a sense kind of this
necessary unity that i'm talking about
and then like i don't think for example
you can make an infinitely large
pool of superfluid healing you'll be
constrained by like okay how many
planets can we put together how large
can be the lab where we do this and then
like extrapolate to for example
how do you create the largest brain so
i don't know if the largest brain is
going to be the size of a house or the
size of jupiter
but chances are that or the metaverse
itself or the metaverse itself yeah
of course like you know if we break some
further assumptions of like
no and uh
well so what i just presented is like
the argument for
why
there is a largest experience and then
the argument for okay so that's one part
the second one is
that experiences are not infinitely
different from one another then like if
you take my experience right now and
your experience right now
there is a finite set of what we call
just noticeable difference differences
that if i were to change my experiences
slightly in one way or another i can do
a finite set of transformations
that take me from where i'm at to like
the experience you are having
uh you can call that the edit distance
for two particular experiences
and then um
essentially
i love your lexicon
i i actually think of is a lot of kind
of like in the future we will have
hopefully an experience photoshop this
kind of you can
like create an experience like you would
create a picture but like it also
contains tactile sensations you know
smell thoughts philosophy
um having my computer charger real quick
yeah
yeah yeah so
um yeah for for the audience i mean is
that or
if you're listening to so basically
uh experiences cannot be
uh infinitely different because there's
always like a finite edit distance
between them and also they cannot be
infinitely close essentially they
collapse into one another and that is
because
if they are less different than a just
noticeable difference
from the inside they're
undistinguishable so
so in that sense that actually gives you
a hard limit
to basically
whether two experiences are the same or
not because if they're subjectively
indistinguishable you can just call them
the same experience
and this argument shows that basically
you can take the entire stasis of
consciousness and discretize it and you
will actually be able to
name with a number each possible
experience but no bounds
where you'll never come to the end of
possibilities
well you you you
my suspicion is that they are they're
all already there
what would for
this already be everything
basically
it's already the pure potential of
nothing being everything
yeah i mean it's the the universal wave
function is the superposition of all
possibilities and it's it just is
i mean same thing the universal wave
function is the same thing the mystics
called dao brahman god etc yeah i i
i uh i look forward to when the um
lexicon is finally popularized in a
synthesis and yeah
and then just abundance and prosperity
this
and there'll be continued parallax in
memetic discourse
but it will not be about
um
as petty ego as what it is
today
it will be about uh cool things like
which
um which flavor of consciousness
uh to explore
next yes
we do have a a bit of a head start with
a qri glossary maybe you can share a
link or at least the name of it it's
easy to uh to find
um
is that online too
yeah yeah yeah
it's in our our main website the qri
glossary and it's uh
uh
i mean it's not
completely up to date but it's pretty up
to date like
i
i would still read it like for a lot of
people actually like probably starting
like their journey of like trying to
understand what quality research
institute is all about i know like it's
not easy because you start reading one
article and like it links to other
articles and they're all kind of
mutually
co-dependent
but it's you know codependent arising
you know it's
you can't avoid that to some extent
but uh the glossary might be actually a
really good place to start because all
of the terms that you will see in other
articles are
or most of them are like defined in here
like including the the ones i was just
uh talking about like the state space of
consciousness and
um just noticeable differences and
things like that
um
and yeah i mean in the end i i do think
maybe to to leave you with is uh going
to be that
i mean i think like cataloging the
status of consciousness is awesome
but also i'm super excited a more narrow
task which is
cataloging flavors of awakening
and uh this is yeah basically something
mike johnson is quite uh interested in
at the moment
which is like if you look at like
three let's say three kinds of like
buddhism like theravada
like like they all ultimately have kind
of like a ability to reduce suffering
significantly and
cause
interesting experiences
um
uh um
basically you can say that maybe the
theravada ideal is kind of like these
people who are
extremely peaceful they're ex that's
kind of the flavor of that awakening
whereas maybe the the flavor of mahayana
is like extremely loving you know
wanting loving kindness for everybody
that's like the flavor of their
awakening
and then vajrayana is maybe they're
energized they're like very alive and
like that is the flavor of that
awakening i mean in the end like they're
all great and uh whichever suits your
needs better might be the one you should
aim to but uh i suspect there's many
more flavors many more flavors of
awakening to be discovered
i love that along with the cataloging
flavors of awakening what we can do with
what we're
building within the limit society and
igniting global awakening is we can
potentially
have these different
um satori moments
that can be shared with qri in their
process
must have been battery
love you guys
it's beautiful reality
beautiful oneness
no matter what's happening
just
sure
oh hello
sorry the battery ran out of the other
computer
i'm glad that you got back on
a little uh
had a little monologue about
perfection that everything is it was
quite it's quite beautiful it's playful
hopefully
kept uh kept the viewers happy and
engaged and
andres what i was saying was that it
would be nice with everything we're
doing with no limited society and
igniting global awakening and capturing
satori to also collaborate with mike in
cataloging flavors of awakening with qri
and i would love i would love to explore
doing that
together because obviously i've i've
shifted a lot like this has become more
and more of my natural state and it's
it's very peaceful and it's very one and
it's very
eternity or perfection that's looking
and
it's very becoming more and more empty
itself and more and more in pure service
everything that i've
been really excited about architecting
is just naturally spontaneously
unfolding into
that those planetary infrastructures and
so it's it's a different flavor than
like you were describing there are
i've i've i've seen a lot of uh as has
been said in zen there's a lot of drunk
on emptiness
and yeah and there's there's also a lot
of uh
avoiding
void
as well
so um
those that those that are uh
awake presence yet not depleted of
conditioning
yes yeah so there's a lot of flavors
here to um catalog and explore and uh
and so it'll be
exciting to see how that
unfolds together as well that's a cool
one i like that
it's a good play and we have a we have
plenty of people we have over 100 people
in the
society so it would be cool to be able
to
collaborate and explore that
so
one of the things that i would like to
wrap with here is um
for you is the
density of consciousness is the
um the difference between the let's just
call it light
in um
in electromagnetic flux or the quantum
electrodynamics
um is the difference in density
um
and i know you were mentioning that not
every single always is this always
coherent and harmonic and this is always
dissonant
but would you say that the
that the density
um what exactly is happening in the
quantum electrodynamical flux of light
across the densities that then signal
said solar plexus chakra versus said
crown chakra
yeah uh
this is
uh where actually the the picture i i
never was able to show you but i from
the same healing trauma from neurology
the healing trauma of neural needling
has that uh the picture um
well you'll find it a little bit below
uh but basically it's um
a map of the state space of
consciousness
with two axes
uh which is like energy and then
information content
to do
further below uh
further like it's significantly further
blue
that uh the one above so
that
yeah if you zoom in on that um
basically
uh the
y-axis
is
essentially the energy level
whereas the x-axis is information
content
and uh basically if you take the mt
like
what will happen is that you will go to
greater energy levels and like that's
kind of unavoidable it's like a matter
of dose i mean of course if you're not a
non-responder that might not happen but
i mean roughly speaking energy levels
are organized in these kind of like
five or six categories which is like
from threshold to chrysanthemum and
chrysanthemum basically you you're still
two-dimensional
um uh two-dimensional energy flux
whereas like in magic eye level actually
you get like this complex
three-dimensional hallucinations and
three-dimensional embodied feelings
waiting room it actually becomes
hyperbolic uh hyperbolic 3d space or
higher dimensional and in breakthrough
um
it's always hyperbolic space and it's
almost always higher dimensional um and
is like open there's like this other
quality of like openness to it um
so it's not contained uh waiting room is
like contained and
uh that's similar to like the difference
between like being a sphere versus that
or being a torus that type of
transformation
um
uh but then like that's not all the
information you need because also
basically what is
the density of the content of the
information matters a lot because you
could be in a very energized state
where for example you're in kind of this
very crazy spaceship with machine elves
and a lot of complex machinery and very
irreducibly complex objects are
happening
um
that would be kind of like in the middle
kind of like this like high energy but
also high information content
whereas um
to actually have like a perfectly clean
experience of the unconditioned or the
pure consciousness you have to be all
the way up and all the way to the left
so that's like
high energy
but close to zero information content
where basically things
are experienced as kind of like this
infinitely reflecting
mirror
room type universes oftentimes
of hyperbolic geometry um the reason is
that energy also curves uh phenomenal
space uh
some i mean again i'm not saying this
because i want to believe it or because
i i came up you know i just came up with
it one afternoon like you know the
armchair philosopher this is the result
of like the think tank process of like
like no like talking to super smart
people doing this very seriously um and
yeah like basically there is this
thing in physics called the hamiltonian
of a system which is like what are the
equations that describe each energy
level of a given system
and essentially like for a given energy
level you can still arrange that energy
in many different ways like for example
um
what you will often see is that for a
let's say a magic eye level or a waiting
room level
all the energy could actually be
concentrated in the form of color qualia
so like it's the brightest possible blue
or the brightest pink possible
imaginable or like it's beyond
imaginable but like extremely bright
color
so bright that actually it has kind of a
physicality of its own we call it a
hyper blue or hyperpink the
hyperversions of the colors
but then that energy can also shift
towards for example a feeling of
embodied energy waves and that that can
shift towards the thought forms or
emotions
in in general the typical experience is
going to be a kind of a balance of
energies in each of the sensory
modalities and each of the inner
modalities
but you can concentrate the energy in
one form or another and basically
um
what you will find is that for a given
energy level
there's still an
huge number of possible configurations
so like just as like there's so much
poetry about like all the beauty of
being a normal human being like why is
there is going to be a huge amount of
poetry about waiting room dmt level
because there's like waiting room dmt
level that is flavored in a certain way
and then there's completely different
flavors and i suspect there's actually
even more flavors of dmt waiting room
experiences then there are flavors of
you know normal human experiences
and yeah i actually think this is
actually like a physical energy which
ultimately will be the same as like
energized consciousness
and
each of the discrete energy bands are
actually phase transitions
um not so different than for example ice
going to liquid going into vapor
except that we're talking about
electromagnetic
flux tubes and what happens when you
energize those and like at first you
know things just become a little bit
brighter if you energize it more you
know then you have kind of this phase
transition where like things rather than
just
attention moving and kind of like field
lines you can even move in kind of like
um
uh
whole planes like this is one of the
crazy things that happened in high
energy consciousness that like
it's not so much that you focus on
things one at a time anymore it's more
like you're sending pads of awareness
and attention everywhere so that's a
phase transition in like the very nature
of attention and
it gets crazier
the higher you go in the energy uh
parameter
and like knotted consciousness as well
like there's a lot of those like a lot
of the
you know machine health high information
content high energy are like patterns of
like knotted consciousness with their
own exotic acoustics and
again completely exotic exotic we don't
have really words for them but they're
they're real they exist they're possible
configurations of consciousness
um
i'm thinking like what would be the the
best metaphase something like
it's kind of like a mod
mod and gelatine
uh if you vibrate like imagine you have
like a a bucket of mud and gelatin
and if you vibrate it enough they start
to kind of like blend into each other
and they they form waves and they
they change the way in which energy
propagates i think it's similar like
that like yes these like configuration
of electromagnetic binding patterns
if you energize it you will get these
phase transitions again it's not the
same as from liquid to to to gas
but it's of the type except that in the
electromagnetic domain and like that's
yeah we don't really have words for
those different phases yet
so
the
so the
the
high energy
um
so would it be
would it be fair to say
that
low
low energy
is
like
form
low energy is it's going to be more
solidified for sure okay all right give
me one one second
yeah we'll we'll wrap soon
yeah
yeah because of the
situation
yeah for sure so
um
again communicate our love to
we'll do it we'll do it
we're very grateful to be able to use
the
um computer tools so
so low energy is more solid like form in
general in general higher energy as we
go up here towards this breakthrough
that that is
uh
like air more like air yeah more like
air and more like air dancing
yeah
and and uh uh air currents air currents
inter penetrating themselves yeah
yeah
and and and even higher
it becomes plasma
so it doesn't end in the
we're a gas it becomes plasma afterwards
cool and then
and then
and then
so
when it's
low
content
it's
like coherence and then high information
content is
what what yeah what's the difference
uh
so
it depends on just basically
i mean it's very related to how
symmetrical like what does a state of
consciousness that's
um like pure pure noise i'm i don't even
know have i felt something that's like
pure noise before you may have uh i mean
the classic example is actually
listening to white noise
and
that actually has like hedonic effects
it it
very high nose noise works as a
dampening
it has a dampening effect so basically
if you are feeling very stressed out
actually listening to white noise can be
soothing because it's going to
override the patterns of dissonance oh
but even
yeah yeah yeah which is like why you
know
waves crashing in the ocean can be so
therapeutic if you're very stressed out
it's just
um a weight is considered pure noise
the sound that waves make is a certain
type of noise that's called stochastic
fractal noise but it's it is very
approximates white noise okay okay so
then then there's uh
there's the pure noise and then there's
what's uh what's low information content
so any anything where
uh
nothing is like sticking out there's
nothing
if something is salient it's going to be
like let's say a central point
uh in your experience
very little information like very
coherent experiences so
so equanimous even evenness yeah
evenness
so so but then isn't
uh is
your noise not also it's not even that's
the opposite of even
it is
the opposite
except that there's also nothing salient
because there's nothing that sticks out
everything is so so
diluted by this
uh total total noise that there's no
nothing salient and uh in that sense
uh it's very similar
um
but
they are complete opposites when it
comes to the hedonic effects that
basically
the lowest information content
for a given energy range
will be the most pleasant variety for
that energy
whereas total noise is actually
perfectly
neutral
so then what you may ask is like well
where then where is the suffering
and suffering is actually somewhere in
the middle but it's actually more the
most the worst suffering is generally
like
kind of like close to zero information
like so like the the complete left
column that would be perfect bliss
but then one step off to the right
kind of like around there exactly
like that's where like a huge potential
for dissonance exists
because that's kind of like a an uncanny
valley where
different types of symmetry can both
coexist
and they may be interfering with one
another so
it's a it's much better for example to
listen to
uh an orchestra and white noise at the
same time
than listening to an orchestra and a
different orchestra playing a completely
different song that they're like not in
tune with one another because
i mean that one is more ordered there
there's less you know there's less noise
but there's more dissonance because
they're going to be clashing with each
other so in a sense
two different like patterns of
conditioning
emerging
is like two different orchestras playing
different
music and yeah that creates so much
dissonance and yeah
and okay beautiful and wow and then i
love that so andres and then
um
would we say that then when
there's a
when there's a
so again a a very
a high
uh energetic
and a low information content
so
there's a
air
plasma
like interpenetration
and
that
there's an evenness
yeah
no specific thing is sticking out yeah
this is the fabric or the substratum
yeah
substrate so yeah
yeah
and then would that also be with this
corner this top left corner
would this also be
somewhat analogous to what was called
like
uh indra's net
yeah
it's gonna be very related uh
i would say indra's net experiences
are
also just slightly to the right because
they they do have a fractal structure
and in that sense they do have a little
bit of information
but it's very little so most interest
net experiences which again like they're
real they're a valid state of
consciousness
you can experience meditation or
psychedelics
around there
they just have a little bit of
information and so it's actually they're
fine they tend to be very pleasant and
euphoric and insightful and beautiful
um but they're not the perfect zero
information state because that one
doesn't even have fractal structure like
that's the the crazy thing like
i mean that's like one of the beautiful
thing about like many mathematical
fractals that like
you see all this apparent complexity but
actually
the whole thing can be created with a
tiny program or like a tiny equation so
it's like all these apparent is actually
just very little information and and the
same with that indra's net
this like these you know spheres
endlessly repeating the
the reflections of the spheres within
the spheres and so on
yeah that has very little information
but it still has some information
and i would say that for example
interest net type experiences are more
common than like dmt
than on 5mao dmt because in five million
dmt you're actually just much more
likely to go to the pure zero
information state that's the the
attractor the natural attractor of it
and that one doesn't have a fractal
structure it's just
pure pure void
so
the
the
soul
differentiator between people having
experiences of oneness that include
the
indra's net
slash
um
mandelbrot benoit mandelbrot style
fractals
is that
is that there is still some sort of a
small
fractal-like structure or pattern or
something that is
versus when you go all the way over here
this is where there's no
fractal like there's no
repeating pattern there's nothing to
fixate
on
there's just a
an absolute evenness
that is uh yeah that's
okay so now my follow-up question to
that is would an example of this
corner
here
would it also be
um
examples like like these or this yeah
yeah yeah the one on the left bottom
left like
yeah that picture yeah
yeah that would be a classic interest
net experience
so what's what is um
what is like this
uh but for your top left corner
i mean it could be i mean like it it it
literally can be like your experience
has like fragmented into components
where each of those components have a
perfect copy
of the content of the entirety of the
experience
so you will have this recursive fractal
structure it doesn't go infinitely down
because there's like a finite resolution
to consciousness or at least our type of
consciousness
but it can go pretty deep like maybe
seven levels or something like that
which is actually really stunning if you
experience it he's like oh i didn't know
fractals could be this detailed and it's
going to be much more detailed than
the fractals that you see in a silver
state for sure um
but there's like many configurations i
mean this is like
visual audit audio tactile ender inter
relationships there's many there's not
one interest net just as there's not one
fractal right there's
many possible intra interest net
experiences
and almost all of them they're very
blissful and beautiful not all of them
because some of them may actually be
you know like fractal noise or fractal
dissonance which is a unstable and
that's why they're not like attractors
usually these experiences when they're
like fractal
they tend to be very loving and
beautiful because that's the type of
energy that actually makes it stable and
is like stabilizing um
so typically when somebody says they
have like a interest net experience
they're going to yeah be describing a
beautiful experience not always but
that's the typical
so what would a visualization if we were
to
explain that this
is more like
the
the natural state of suchness
that buddhist talking about if we were
to
um
have uh select other visuals for
audience
which
yeah which other ones or what would we
look up to
i would say
the like a calmed calmed taurus
so maybe if you search like
harry ball theorem and taurus
combat doris maybe yeah there you go
like the
the one on the
top left i guess
yeah that would be kind of like the
unconditioned
like there's just no information there
because like there's there's no
structure to it the the lines are all
perfectly common
so if you take 5mu dmt
you arrive at the unconditioned state
it's like yeah that's kind of the
electromagnetic field with no features
it's just pure
void and it's very peaceful it's
completely peaceful there's no problem
in there
so when you say
that
there's this
em field with no features because
everything you pure void
every everything is this in the hairy
ball theorem it's because every
thing is
just in its
perfect
uh
alignment alignment
imperfect aligned flux
yeah
and that's the
beauty that like
you don't do these by
doing surgery you don't do this by
individually going to every point
and like putting the vector in that
direction
what you do is you heat up
the whole
structure and then let it cool so you
basically do the annealing process and
that's exactly how you
yeah i remember exactly that's one of
it's one of the beautiful things about
what does it mean for a
conscious entity to heat themselves up
so that means to take their density from
lower to higher
in a heating up process and then as
there is a creation of potentially more
um
coherence is that right alignment
yeah with all that then there's a
following process of sort of cooling to
to take that
to lock in said more natural state
exactly on the lower density level
things are more flexible so you can do a
lot of search what we call neural search
over there
and find solutions that then as you cool
down they stick with you and uh you'll
be better aligned and this is both at
the level of beliefs and attitudes but
also at the micro level that like even
like certain kinds of like chronic pain
or like
energy blockages in your body that also
can go away through this process
and i mean to me it's very beautiful
that like
again like you don't do this by indiv
surgically trying to fix everything
you do this by instantiating a process
that gives rise to a new kind of
self-organization so it's like the
paradoxical thing that if you want to
get something more ordered
you first disordered more and then you
cool it down so uh
because otherwise it's computationally
intractable so and in general i think
that's how we think of a
future technologies at qri is a lot less
of like oh how do we like fix this
particular part of the nervous system is
more
how do we kick start a holistic process
that has self-healing
properties yeah
cool so so how does when the
consciousness
is heating up in the annealing process
um
how does how does their creation of a
a more
entropic or disordered state
but yet there is still the alignment or
the coherence like how is the hairy ball
both perfect alignment but also entropic
in a process
uh
that might be
the thing where
you're simultaneously instantiating
a unified field
while keeping the information of the
other fields as well
and i mean again like that that will
happen at some energy levels
i think if you
raise the energy far enough it just
can't happen i think like it will just
basically just collapse into the uh
basically the
pure you know pure consciousness type of
realms um
but if you can keep it i mean it's kind
of like this whole idea of like like you
need the balance of forces like it's
again like you need to find exactly the
place
where kind of the pure consciousness and
the form can simultaneously co-exist and
it's going to be a corner pace
like you need to balance a lot of forces
and keep the balance there or it's going
to
deviate to something else
yeah so
is that goldilocks his own is very much
like goldilocks is that the goldilocks
zone yeah cool that makes sense
the more that
the reality becomes
formless it simultaneously
is formed and
it's sort of like
you this lower chakrik
formness is where the start is and then
there's this um
higher density formlessness
and then
the
uh
form is empty emptiest form kicks in
because the emptiness that is the
formlessness
kicks in
as you
as you sort of reach said higher there's
there the differentiation ceases
um
and that the simultaneity
is
experienced the simultaneity's
experience and the differentiation
between emptiness and form or
formlessness and form um
no longer is pronounced
what was pronounced is no longer as
pronounced
um
so
would would you then say that this um
the hairy ball
theorem is as
uh
close to
expressing what is in this um high
energy low information content corner
uh yeah i mean well that would be the
the com the taurus
how what do we look up to
i looked up combed
left uh
they're both they're both uh so the
donut there would be the comet taurus
and the hairy ball
would be the other one
oh another one
the one you the one you have selected
already yeah yeah and then which other
one are you talking about so and then
the sphere that is right next to it on
top
oh this one
yeah that one is the one where there's
an ego because the structure is such
that you cannot comb it
whereas the torus you can actually comb
it
and so you can actually get
no sticking point at all
okay wait a second so in this one which
is the the taurus yes in the taurus you
can comb it yes
and in in this one um where
there's a center is that the idea is
that there's a center right yeah whereas
in this one in the taurus there's no
center right yeah okay so in the taurus
there's no center meaning it's empty of
self
yeah meaning that it is the field
yeah
we could say that yeah yeah okay
okay and then meaning that in this one
there's a real big solidity in the
center yeah and then why can't it can't
be combed because of the solidity in the
center
uh
there's a proof and it's a little bit
complicated but uh it has to do with
euler's number but but the
simplify it as much as you can or oh my
goodness give us you know just give us
the essence of what why can't the
contracted ego itself with the center
why can't that be combed
and what do we mean by cone
yeah yeah so all the meaning alignment
right i mean this is this is very
interesting like if you pay attention to
how
um your attention moves around from
second to second
um
for most people in most circumstances is
going to be
your attention is kind of like there's
several operations like one is like
scanning for salient objects
you fixate your attention briefly there
if there's nothing more salient it kind
of exhausts the saliency
and then
you that information you take it into
the self basically there's kind of this
back and forth between
paying attention to the things around
you
and then like evaluating the relevance
for yourself and there's this back and
forth and that back and forth
creates this viscosity or this kind of a
center of mass that is
not ideal i mean basically it is a kind
of like energy sink or blockage and it's
also resting on an illusion
fundamentally like this idea of an
endearing metaphysical self is kind of
part of what feeds or fuels that kind of
dynamic
and uh instead if you do a lot of
meditation and you remove or at least
like lessen or
um
liquefy at the very least that sense of
self the attention patterns are going to
in a sense not be coagulating or like
always kind of coming back to the center
and instead the information is going to
be available throughout the experience
it's just a different way of like
organizing information
and
um
and in that sense you know you you can
say that like yeah i mean like given the
structure of most people's experiences
because they have kind of the center of
mass
things are more likely to be brittle or
dissonant or waves of energy have like
more blockages because there's that
center of mass doesn't transmit energy
very well whereas in kind of the fully i
guess
decentralized calmed state
uh there's no
center of mass and the energy
information is more kind of in some
sense like holographically distributed
throughout the entire experience and
there's nothing in that experience that
you assign as like oh this is me
fundamentally like everything is just
you know an appearance of a form
and uh and when i say comp i actually
mean it quite literally in like how your
attention
is
spreading in your experience that like a
fully combed experience
is one where for example attention
moves in kind of a homogeneous wave and
you're kind of scanning your experience
without any
blockage or anything any resistance
and in that sense that will be kind of
the torus it's kind of like there's
waves of attention just moving through
but they're not causing pinch points
they're not
self overlapping or self intersecting
whereas
okay cool keep going yeah whereas with a
sense of self your attention kind of
like goes one place and then bounces
back goes one place and bounces back
and that quality causes a certain kind
of dissonance and as long as you're
shaped like that
it doesn't matter if you rearrange the
things in your life or the world
you're still going to be processing the
world through that shape and that shape
will has an inherent kind of dissonance
associated to it i mean that sense is
less than ideal
okay
okay so then
um
i love how i love how at the two hour
mark we are getting into like
like one of the
like
coolest parts of the like do you feel
relevant with that like do you feel like
this is one of the coolest parts of the
convo so far yeah yeah definitely
definitely
that's interesting so
um
uh do you do you feel like we can have a
window of a little bit more time to run
through this uh
of what's coming arising right now to
play and exactly yeah i i should go at
seven but yes uh we can go a little bit
longer okay okay cool thanks for that
heads up great
um
and thanks for uh the whole show
together it's been
definitely it's been so good we finally
we reconvened our energies for play
after
a nice a nice gap of exploring
um what was in our excitement space and
now
there's
so many new fresh takes with us both
harmonizing on this
and i also after having dan ingram on
the eprc i heard that you guys are a
part of that which is so often
and
um
and it's it's really great to
um to see what's been unfolding for you
guys and to just hear how much more
precise
um you are
and
um and and it could be cool for us to
maybe something like twice a year
like every
something like do a session
with uri just to um to further
explore what is being synthesized in the
science and spirituality space here and
also relate that to what's happening as
we explore these higher um explorations
of consciousness and those densities and
so it'll be uh
in this in this uh theories of
everything actually could be kind of
cool for qri to um be featured by kurt
jaymungal in the theories of everything
um
podcasts as well
um
so just uh just to wrap a little bit
here on the on this um um so in so in
essence
on on the
um
on the left
um and what do you call this is a taurus
but what do you call this a puff no well
ready yeah sphere it's
yeah
it's the puff that the condom bubble
over the head
yeah um
so you guys call it a sphere right you
guys just caught a sphere okay cool i i
just wrote puff i thought puff was so
funny because puff puff makes it a
little more able to be um non uh
because it doesn't look exactly
spherical right it looks
like it's a little bit
um off sphere or is it exactly sphere
it doesn't matter actually as as long as
the the topology is of a sphere yes you
cannot accomplish general topology
sphere and versus the general topology
is donut with the whole empty center
okay so so again so now we have this
taurus in the sphere the taurus is empty
of self these higher densities of
consciousness emptying of self um
so this is uh and you were taught you
were discussing this there's no
coagulation in this
yeah that's so interesting so
the
there's not an experience or there's
just experience yeah there's just
arising
there's just happenings
not to an experiencer there's no doer
it's just happenings appearances and
then
there's a
um the attention when the attention in
this um
uh donut um the attention is like
massive waves
of attention with no
um fixations
just massive waves of attention and then
um
and then in the sphere
the sphere one is
a
um the sense of self is there the ego is
there all the conditioning the
coagulation
is there and then now the combing means
it can't be combed because as soon as
you start combing there's a prickly hair
of condition
is that right yeah right yeah yeah yeah
okay cool cool that's dope wow this is
this is quite interesting i um i'm i'm
really feeling like much of what i've
been
um synthesizing and distilling in the
spiritual mystic literature and direct
experience is
um very aligned with what is what with
what you're sharing here with what is
being explored here scientifically as
well which is very fascinating actually
this donut versus sphere um could could
you say that this sphere is the lower
densities where the
um
you're more in like the yellow
ray and then
but but not yeah but i i see what you're
yeah because there's both in in every
single one but um and then this shift
more to the doughnut the taurus is more
of the higher densities that are more
empty of self
so it could almost look like a spectrum
from this to this
to an extent yet yeah yeah and uh
it is i think for sure that um
basically with the lower densities
uh i mean you could call it like there's
more in in fighting or like more
fighting with yourself because
if you're like full of structures like
that essentially the the fields will
not be able to arrange themselves
in a way that they don't self-intersect
and that is the thing that you want to
avoid i mean everything like that's
basically the source of suffering here
that
basically whenever the waves of energy
inside you collide
that causes dissonance
so you have to reshape yourself in such
a way that they actually just flow
without colliding and that is the the
high valence configurations
so cool yeah
flow without colliding
wow
great let's uh
let's let's wrap um
so
this has been fascinating so you would
say that this sort of um
this is one of the best visualizations
potentially the sphere to the torus of
the
um the densities of consciousness as
they appear
yeah it would be one of maybe a couple
that i would probably select but i'll
yeah i'll have to think of a
a clean way of explaining it i might
make a video about it yeah that's dope
okay so
um
yeah and so by the way for everyone
that's tuning in
um thank you we love you
we're so [ __ ] grateful fam
thank you thank you definitely
and
um
and you can find the link to andrea's
youtube channel in the bio of the video
where he has a lot of other content on
his channel that helps unpack what he's
been talking about
um and
so subscribe to his channel go and check
it out um like his content there
um if this
video also brought you value give it a
like help the algorithm uh subscribe to
the channel if you haven't yet also
share the video with other people that
you feel like this would resonate with
energy and consciousness baby the
synthesis
of spirituality baby qri
and um also uh leave us a comment below
with your thoughts on the episode we
would love to also hear from you
and also you can support qualia research
institute they have a
a donate button you can go and support
them
and uh join their efforts because
they're independent they're still not um
yeah it's still completely independent
not yeah so there's um it's really
important basically for us to um
collectively
uh fund their efforts and so um get
behind them if you believe in what
andres has been sharing if it's really
resonant with you go and support them so
they can continue they've been bringing
on
new people onto staff and taking on new
projects which is awesome and there are
all these like new fresh people that are
um
graduating or that are just really
fascinated about this field and that are
getting involved in their efforts so
they're also
scaling up which is great um
i will
i will stop the
screen sharing over here and that yeah
yeah my brother um thank you again
andres infinite love for you brother
this is
so beautiful what a great
um
meeting what a great meeting of our of
us after so
long
sorry yep our energy is releasing so
beautifully here
thank you again so much and congrats on
all of the groups
it's been it's been awesome learning
from you and everything that you guys
have been achieving so great job
and uh thank you so much and yeah yeah
in one one word here i guess like it's
that
the reason why we're a non-profit is
basically we think that uh
uh yeah basically we actually need to
keep the science away from commercial
interests that like you know we want to
actually have like a science
consciousness science of well-being it
has to be yeah really pure like it
cannot be like influenced by okay what
is the next product cycle going to say
that we should say or what is it that we
should say that will make people like us
actually what we want to say is just the
truth you know actually whatever will
actually help as many people as possible
in that sense yeah we are committed to
being a non-profit we will eventually
have like spin-off companies as like
this research actually becomes like
available for like diagnostic tools or
like therapies but uh for the time being
it's a nonprofit and
we basically do kind of like require
funding to maintain the nonprofit effort
to the point where we can ultimately
license uh technologies or therapies
diagnose the tools but yeah for the time
being any support is super super
appreciated so and uh and also yeah
thank you so much for
giving me yeah this space and wonderful
questions and conversations it's a great
talking to another uh open individualist
it's very funny
it's really fun thank you
so much beautiful thank you thank you
and let's um let's go ahead i will end
the stream but you and i will stay in
the studio for just a quick minute okay
once
bye everyone infinite love infinite
please love everybody